Hello everyone. Very happy to be with
you.
Um
I'm generally seen as the Islam guy and
I talk about that big issue, but seeing
that this is a Christian revival uh
conference and the fact that Islam and
Christianity, there's something of a
symbiotic relationship going on.
I have to actually talk about both and
because it's really all interrelated.
And so what I'd like to start off with
when I think of problems
um is well, what what's the first
things? What's the first premise of the
problem? And I often think that many
people don't really see it or don't talk
about it. We tend to talk about
symptoms.
Islam itself in the West, in Europe, in
the UK, I see it as a symptom. I don't
see it as an inherent or innate problem
and it's a symptom of essentially the
weakening or the dying of Christianity
in the West. So how did that happen? And
one of the thoughts that's I've been
that's been percolating in my mind and
I've been thinking about and talking
about quite often
is the idea that one of the problems
with Christianity in the modern era is
that it has in very many ways adopted a
materialist paradigm, not unlike
atheists and secularists. And by that, I
don't mean materialistic as in covetous.
I mean it in a more philosophical sense.
A materialist paradigm in the sense that
all that is real, let's say from an
atheist point of view, all that is real
is what? It's the material, right? It's
the physical world. It's what I can see,
feel, touch and measure. And all this
abstract talk about your morality and
your religion and all this sort of thing
is usually jettisoned and that's one of
the problems, but
I fear and I think and I see that much
of Christianity in all of its
manifestations in the modern era has
adopted this worldview despite the
theological uh
veneer of what they say. So in other
words, a Christian can of course express
profound theological truisms, but at the
same time
um it you know, as they say, the proof
is in the pudding and what I'm seeing is
so how is a Christian becoming a
materialist paradigm in a philosophical
sense?
If you look at what if I speak to a
Christian, what is the greatest evil
that you can engage in? I think a lot of
people will say what a atheist would say
which is physical harm, okay? Physical
physically harming someone and much
worse of course killing someone.
And I agree of course those are great
evils. No one would argue that. But
unbeknownst to most Christians, that was
actually more of a minor aspect of the
message of Christianity. The entire
ethos, the the morality that was
created. And in short before I
elaborate, the problem with materialist
Christianity which in many ways has like
I said permeated the world view of all
Christians is that it perfectly comports
with secularism and atheism and that is
why Christianity is still allowed to
live side by side with a secular or even
atheistic world um
environment because it also agrees all
that we want to do is make sure no one's
physically hurt, there's no violence.
But the question now becomes what
happened to morality?
That was a word that used to be pivotal
and important and fundamental to
something like Christianity.
Where is what is there morality anymore?
And I'm not talking of course about
individual Christians, I'm sure there
are many devout Christians still are in
the world, but it's not something that
is socially acknowledged or something
much less that is socially pursued that
we talk about.
Okay, so and once one I think this is my
realization the when I think about it
and how morality is not
is not
Western people and Christians will say
they're moral but again, it's through a
materialist paradigm and you know that
by simply looking at what used to be the
greatest sins and the greatest evils for
a society
and all of them are to various degrees
completely accepted for by Christians
today.
And um
all one has to do is look at the sexual
mores of the West today
and very few Christians will even argue
or or or talk about it or even dispute
it and they'd be of course uh
scandalized to feel like they have to
talk about it. But if you look at
historic Christianity biblical
Christianity, Christianity in all of its
forms, something like sexual mores,
sexual sins, that was one of the
pinnacles and the one of the most
unquestioned aspects of Christianity. So
you see, this is why why is it not being
mentioned? Because well, no one's
hurting anyone. And so that's what I
mean. That's a perfect example of how a
Christian adopts the materialist
worldview. Now there used to be
something and um just to make it simple
you may have heard of I'm sure you you
have of course many Catholics, Anglicans
of the seven deadly sins which actually
very much informed the worldview of
Christians in the pre-modern era.
And they are I often miss but let's see
uh wrath, greed, gluttony, envy, lust,
um
sloth and I always miss one.
Pride. Oh yeah, the worst one.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, I know. The root of them all.
Yeah, you're right. Okay.
So think about those seven things now.
Okay, that is what a Christian society
thought about. Now these are all
metaphysical. They're not material.
Okay? These were metaphysical
principles. This is what Christianity
was all about. Notice, killing is not
one of the seven deadly sins. Why?
Because it's a byproduct. Of course it's
evil and you shouldn't do it but it
wasn't seen as a root cause. Now when I
look at these the seven deadly sins
which were fundamental to a Christian
society, Christian
um
to Christendom essentially for centuries
up until actually quite recently
not only are they not something that we
talk about or something we condemn, they
are in fact what we now celebrate and a
bunch of our economy is based on it.
And we call ourselves Christians and we
live with it and we live in peace with
this and I find that very interesting.
Pride, pride of course is exalted.
Pride, you know there's pride month,
think about that.
Uh lust, that's everywhere you look.
It's it's it's promoted. It's it's
um glamorized. Envy, just think social
media. Okay, um gluttony.
Turn TV on, everything's about, you
know, putting images of food. Sloth. So
it's kind of amazing that to me these
are the principal issues. These are the
first things that were actually at the
heart of a Christian order and they've
just been completely so jettisoned and
very few Christians even understand this
and that's the point. This is so subtle
and so incremental [snorts]
that um and the reason is the best way I
can put it is because Christians one way
or the other over the decades and
possibly centuries have just adopted a
very materialist worldview which is that
Yeah, we talk about the afterlife, we
talk about sin, we talk about being
saved, but in the end when it comes to
society
the old we begin and end with just not
hurting people, okay?
So that's become the ultimate Christian
virtue and it is a virtue, I'm not
arguing that, but I'm trying to say
there was so much more above it which
actually gave meaning uh to life.
Now
what happens when uh society such as
Western society, European society
jettisons what I'm talking about which
is essentially the metaphysical aspect
of Christianity. You can actually call
it the spiritual aspect because the the
physical um or material aspect um what's
the corollary to a metaphysical? The
beyond the physical. Well, that's the
spiritual. And I just think it's funny
because a lot of Christians today when
they say the word spiritual it means
some sort of abstract
fuzzy feeling. Actually, I think to be
spiritual is to be engaged and to
comprehend and try to exercise the meta
metaphysical aspects of Christianity,
the things that are beyond the physical,
that are not measurable, that deal with
morals and ethics, and that sort of
thing.
Now, when all that is jettisoned, as it
has been in recent generations,
a vacuum is created, and that's I think
where we are. And what does nature
abhor? It abhors a vacuum. Enter Islam.
Well, Islam, of course, is its own body
of system. It's its own religion. It has
its own teachings. You know, one can be
very
uh uh hostile to it or critical of it,
and I'm, of course, associated with
those views. But we have to be honest,
it also brings us a sort of traditional
worldview. It knows what a woman is, and
it knows what a man is. It's not
confused about that, for example. And it
has all sorts of things that were very
traditional that Europeans and
Christians would have agreed with
historically.
So, I think that aspect be And it's
confident. So, now you you have a vacuum
in Europe and in the West in general
because of the reasons I've I've
outlined dealing with the
the sort [snorts] of slow melting away
of Christianity based on these
philosophical or epistemological under-
underpinnings.
Now, you have Islam coming in, and it
may have all its problems and all, but
it's still it's very visceral, it's
down-to-earth, and it does offer all of
these things that are filling the
vacuum, okay? And this is why you find
Western people who are turned off and
find no resonance in modern secular
liberal
culture, and they turn to something like
Islam, which on the heart of it doesn't
make any sense.
I wager if those people actually had a
true Christian upbringing or according
to the way I'm trying to describe it,
which is actually much more fused with a
metaphysical understanding, they would
not find Islam appealing. But that's
what I mean, there's a vacuum now, so
that even something that is inherently
inferior inasmuch as it offers something
of a primordial
conservative worldview that still
resonates with all humans, then it
becomes appealing.
And then it's all, especially in this
country, it's coalescing in a very
strange way. As you all know that
there's a new
um blasphemy code or
uh about Islam, a new anti-Islamophobia
or anti-Islam hostility thing.
And of course, this is just this is that
one more way to help Islam to become
more empowered, more entrenched. You
can't even criticize it. And I I haven't
looked as closely as I'd like to the
wording, but it seems it's very fuzzy,
intentionally so, and vague, so that
anything in it it says things like
encouraging hostility or Well, who's
going to decide all that?
And um all of this So, the kind of
Christianity that I'd like to see go
away,
and I'd like to see it sort of bring
back a more traditional form of Chris-
Christianity
that prevailed during Christendom.
It Well, what I call, let's put it this
way, I've tried to coin a word, I call
it doormat Christianity, and I think
this is the modern form of Christianity
whereby Christians are taught, again,
in keeping with what I'm saying, this
materialist idea, to just be doormats,
okay? Christianity begins and ends by
you being a doormat. You're
non-confrontational, you lay down,
everyone walks all over you, and then
you get to pat yourself on the shoulder
and say, "Hey, look, I'm virtuous. I'm
good." It's also a way of make um
it's a way of make make turning of a
vice, cowardice, into a virtue, I think.
And that's why it's become very
prevalent, what I call doormat
Christianity. Doormat Christianity is
not going to stand up against Islam, and
that's what we're seeing.
In fact, that kind of Christianity,
which is completely about just being
passive, who do you think benefits from
it most of all? It's probably the more
of an enemy you are to Christianity, the
more the prevalent form of doormat
Christianity works and serves perfectly
to empower the opposite um
forces.
So, I think Christians need to recapture
and reclaim a sense of morality and a
sense of the metaphysical
because otherwise you don't it's and
again I'm going back to the first
premises. These are These are the
building blocks. Without these I don't
believe that let's say the Islam problem
cannot necessarily be addressed in and
of itself. You can't maintain a sort of
this current culture which with all its
confusions and sort of breakaway from
Christianity and they'd be able to
resist something like Islam. I think
it's all very interconnected. If you go
back and you can easily see this. Go
back a century to the way Western
Europeans and Westerners thought and
Christians thought
you wouldn't have this Islam problem at
all. Even if it existed it would
immediately be solved. So, I think
there's a lot of paralysis going on
amongst Christians because they just
feel like like I said all the best they
can do is to just be just what they've
been taught and bred including like I
said by forces that don't like
Christianity. I saw a video in the Super
Bowl a couple years ago and as you know
Super Bowl commercials
Super Bowl commercials tend to
they're very prominent and they're very
mainstream.
And all it was was images of people
washing people's feet.
But for some reason all the people who
were washing the feet looked like white
traditional Christian people and all the
people getting their feet washed were
well one was a trans man, one was
obviously a it was like on a migrant
border and it was an illegal migrant.
One was a woman committing an abortion
and or at an abortion center and people
are protesting but another woman's
washing her feet. And all and one was a
criminal and a a policeman was washing
his feet. And then it ended up by saying
Jesus didn't hate, he washed feet. And
you can just see that kind of message
how it is completely geared to weakening
Christianity by also but making you
think you're being a good Christian.
Because there's no balance. Of course
Jesus washed feet. That's not my
argument, but there is a balance. Jesus
also hurled tables and made a cord of
whips and drove people and livestock
out. So, there is a room, I believe, for
well, the Bible says so, righteous
indignation that is at least funneled in
a proper way.
And all of that, I guess, is missing and
inasmuch as people don't get that, I
think a lot of this is futile. And I'll
end it by what I call the two swords
theology.
I just wrote a book that came out a few
months ago. It's called the Two Swords
of Christ and it deals with the military
orders and their battles with Islam, the
the Templars and Hospitallers. But,
there's a second meaning to the title
and it's basically in Luke where Christ
says, "If he doesn't have a garment,
sell it and buy a sword." And the
disciples say, "Lord, here are two
swords." And he says, "That is enough."
Now, of course, to modern-day
Christians, that means absolutely
nothing. It doesn't mean anything about
a real sword. But, of course, there's a
long and deep tradition, pre-modern,
especially medieval, understanding which
is the two swords. One is spiritual,
which I think modern Christians still
accept, spiritual warfare, but one is
secular warfare, okay?
And um that's that was the whole
rationale for just war. That was the
whole rationale for um the Crusades,
which I'm sure a lot of people think are
not what they really were. Um
But, so that kind of mentality, and
again, it's not about physical, not
necessarily literal. It's just about
being bold and militant, at least
vocally and in in your approach to
what's happening. Because if you look
back to zoom out and see what's been
going on, it's just been one incremental
slow degrade. And no matter how many uh
no matter what people are saying or
doing or books or conferences, if you
look at the scale, it goes down little
it's like one step forward, three steps
back. And that's how it's been going.
So, I think in part with Christian
revival and the Islam threat, Christians
just need to again go to these first
things and really recapture a sense of a
morality that that is above and beyond
just physical considerations. And once
that is done, because like I said, it's
all interconnected, the Islam question
will become a lot easier to answer
almost instinctively and very natively.
And that's it. Thank you.
>> [applause]
>> Raymond, we've seen a lot in the last
couple of weeks over Ramadan of the real
assertion of Islam in the public space.
Do you think that it's legitimate
for the state institutions to actively
privilege Christianity and actually to
restrain the public assertion of Islam?
And what do you think is at stake if we
don't do that?
I think it's legitimate because that's
what every single other country and
civilization in the world does. They
prioritize their own religion, their own
culture, their own institutions. And
that's considered normal and accepted.
And you know, no Western country would
criticize Saudi Arabia for the way they
live, which is extremely draconian and
doesn't even have room for anyone else.
So I definitely think every civilization
has at least its own right to express
fully its own Christian in this case,
Christian heritage. And any form even
even forms of governments that are based
on Christianity, I don't think there's
anything wrong with that. Now of course,
having invited so many Muslims, that
does cause a problem.
But at the same time, you
[clears throat] can it could just be
rectified by just having a Christian
revival. And it's just straightforward.
Again, this goes back to that doormat
mentality where you know, we have to
hold back our religion to appease
someone else when nobody else would do
that and rightfully so. Because that's
their way. This is their land. This is
how they want to live. So I don't think
the Brits should have any compunction
about resuscitating or resurrecting
their Christian civilization
irrespective of who lives around them.
David, you you mentioned uh
a sort of
burgeoning brand of a kind of Christian
nationalism that can be quite anti-free
speech in some parts. And it was
mentioned earlier this morning that um
you know, when we're going in for this
full-fat version of Christianity, what
we're not going in for is restrictions
on liberties. How do you think you can
get a full-fat Christian revival to
really shore up the foundations of this
country and its culture whilst also
protecting the liberties that people
don't want to lose, like freedom of
speech for example. We don't want
blasphemy laws.
No, we don't. And I don't think there
there is any
as far as I've seen, any call for
blasphemy laws uh from the Christian
right. We we shore up a full-blooded
British Christian revival by telling
people it is okay to believe these
things about our history, which have
been under attack for let's say 30 odd
years.
Uh it's okay to think that the British
Empire was not a complete travesty, that
it was not the subject of all moral
failings for us ever after. It's okay to
think all of these things. But at the
same time, you still have to go to
church. You have to live a sacramental
life. You have to live a Christian moral
life. And you have to understand that
for the past um 200 years,
let's say since uh 1829,
we've lived in a a religiously plural
society. And as much as you might want,
as I do, the predominance of
Christianity within that society,
rejuvenating Christianity does not mean
the suppression of other creeds and
faiths. It means that they must
understand their place in the hierarchy.
Um and
I think [clears throat] that's a a
fairly standard British method, or at
least it was from uh
the repeals of the anti-Roman Catholic
laws uh under Wellington uh until let's
say this uh 25 years ago.
Um
David laid into the Church of England
quite a lot, uh their brand. Um
And some Some the data seems to be quite
mixed when it comes to whether or
whether or not we're seeing a Christian
revival, to what extent, what that
means. We've seen
just this this week we've seen a reports
of Bible sales going up yet again, but
maybe church attendance isn't quite what
it could be, and I think anecdotally we
all know church attendance in the Church
of England is not very good.
So,
do you agree I mean, presumably you
don't agree with [laughter] David's
David's very harsh view of the Church of
England, but do you think that the
Church of England, given its sort of
position in society today, is capable of
of playing the role that it should do in
this revival, or whether that's going to
need to come from other denominations,
perhaps from Catholicism, which maybe is
more prone to traditional forms of
worship than the Church of England has
become?
Yeah, I I think the
the suggestion seems to be that
we've talked about a kind of you know,
full fat Christianity. That's a phrase
that's been used, and of course you you
find that in all kinds of different
denominations of the Christian faith,
and the Church of England is a very
varied thing.
It's not monochrome. You find all kinds
of different forms and expressions of
Christian faith within
within the Church of England. I think
one of the challenges we have, it's
pretty very familiar to other churches
as well, is can we espouse a form of
discipleship, a form of Christian faith
that is disciplined, that is
distinctive, that is different? Um
because there is a criticism, and I you
know, I I take some of that, that
sometimes the Church of England has been
this sort of general cultural
Christianity, um you know, where you
kind of like have Christmas carols, and
you sing you go to Handel's Messiah at
Christmas, and you go get your kids
baptized in the church, and that's
basically as far as it goes. And if
that's all
Christianity is, then it's got nothing
really to offer either either a sort of
secularizing or a paganizing or a
Islamizing society. Um
so, I think that is the challenge. It is
the challenge of not just externally,
but internally, maybe more internally
than externally, that challenge to
develop forms of Christian faith and
discipleship uh that are rigorous, that
are demanding, uh that offer a very
different form of life than you
you can find outside the church. And
I I I know of places where that's
happening in the Church of England. Um
I'm doing a confirmation this coming
weekend of
40 young people in a church here in
Oxford um
who have come to faith recently uh to
really
a very full form of Christian faith. And
so and I and when I go around doing
confirmations, I find that again and
again in churches that the people are
drawn to that. So, I think the Church of
England is still has a future. I think
alongside other churches, I think many
uh this is one of one of those times
when actually we the relationships
between the churches are probably
stronger than they've ever been. Uh and
we need that kind of sense of learning
from one another,
strengthening and encouraging one
another across our churches, encouraging
other each other to be the best that we
can be as the expressions of Christian
faith in this country in this nation.
Now, if anyone has any questions, please
raise your hand. We'll get a microphone
to you and in the meantime give David a
chance to reply. Yeah, I just want to
clarify that my criticism of the Church
of England is entirely of the church at
the hierarchical and particularly at
uh the episcopal level because I think
at the parish level it does
extraordinary things, many of whom are
sitting in this building uh and many of
whom are distributed around this
country, but it is the lanyard class of
the uh of the leadership of the Church
of England and its dominance
particularly by uh a
a
liberal theology going back probably to
the 1970s of a sort that I think has not
only not drawn people in, but has
actively repelled them. That is what has
destroyed the C of E uh as far as I can
see.
>> [applause]
>> Uh so, there's a question here and a
question here.
We'll do it in that order.
This whole conference is based on the
premise that you know, we're moving into
a post-liberal age, but some of the
things that some of you have talked
about and in the way you've addressed
these issues seems to me to be very much
fitting within the liberal paradigm. So,
you know, you says you
talked about the sort of ickiness of
pre-liberal solutions like
uh
deportations and the idea that you know,
we've got to make it okay and restore
the liberal neutrality of it's okay to
be a Christian, okay to think about our
history and our past in a positive
light, rather than saying, "No,
we are the English. We are Christian and
this is what we think." And and not in a
non-liberal, non-neutral sense. So,
we're talking about you know, we don't
want
post-liberal world here, but we're still
operating within the paradigm of
liberalism.
Raymond?
Yeah, I actually agree. Um
that's [clears throat] uh
obviously it's a divergence of opinion,
but I'm inclined to agree with you in
that
this is kind of what I was trying to say
that uh Christianity has sort of been
co-opted by secular liberalism and it's
kind of coincided with it because there
are similarities. The entire Christian
message of you know, love, peace,
tolerance, turning the other cheek, but
to a certain degree we have to realize
it's now being weaponized against
Christianity. And that's the whole
point. There needs to be a balance. You
know, it's not it's not just the doormat
variety. There's also room for the whip
and cords uh analogy, which means
there's also time when Christians need
to get serious and uh get their hands
dirty as it were in the sense. So, I'm
in agreement with you and therefore I
protest that you're associating me with
your remarks.
And I I agree with Ray with Raymond. My
only point about deportations is that
though they may be necessary, they are
not the sole policy uh
policy response to the
de-Christianization
uh and moral relativism of of modern
Britain.
Do you have another question here?
And then we'll go to afterwards. So,
we're uh I think that's Helen's hand.
Um I'll do the deeply unfashionable
thing of outing myself as an
evangelical.
Um
the main source of growth in the British
church, to whatever extent that's going
on in the quiet revival within and
without the Church of England, is
evangelicalism of
varying degrees of Pentecostal and
charismatic varieties.
Um
Evangelicals are very willing to hold
the line on human sexuality.
Yet not in any distinctive way on other
socially conservative issues, I think
it's fair to say. Um so, two questions.
One maybe directly to Graham, as I think
the representative of the evangelical
stream on the panel,
why is that? Why are they Why are
evangelicals willing to be, you know,
martyred, kicked out, lose their
parishes over gay marriage, but not over
other
hot potatoes?
And then to what extent does anyone have
any confidence that it's the growing
uh evangelical influence in the country
that might provide some level of
conservative hope.
Yeah.
If I can just uh
clarify the question a little bit. You
sort of talked about
gay marriage as one thing and then other
hot potatoes. What kind of things did
you have in mind?
Yeah.
>> Uh well, if I can just push back on that
a little bit, I think you'll find I
don't think we've done much on
homosexuality, but we have done a number
of things quite positively about flags
on lamp posts because seems to me that
um
I think it's I think a large part of it
is what we have alluded to this morning.
We are captivated sometimes by a very
kind of middle-class type of
Christianity, which is quite comfortable
with people
who will come along for baptisms and
because they want to get their kids into
the local church school, and they'll
turn up for a little while, and then
they'll kind of leave as soon as the
kids in the school.
Um we were comfortable with that kind of
approach, but we're not very comfortable
with people who want to put flags on
lamp posts who are um uneasy about the
kind of drift towards a secular
um nature of the of the country and so
on. Um
And that affects not just evangelism, it
affects many people within church
circles, not just Anglican church
circles as well. And that's something I
think we need to repent on. And I think
that's where it is. It's captivated to a
kind of middle-class sensibility where
we're quite comfortable with forms of
middle-class religiosity in which you
feel that's fine. We need we'll accept
these, but we would don't want those
people over there. But it seems to me
that there needs to be a sense of, you
know, if if someone is coming to our
church and saying, for whatever reason
they have to come to say,
I I I want to just explore Christian
faith,
the answer should be no, to be yes, you
you come. Whatever that reason is,
people come with all kinds of bad
motives for for discovering Christ. But
if they want to discover Christ, that's
our our job to to teach and share it
with them. So, I think that's some of
some of that reasons. So, we'll go to
Helen and then to John, but David's
going to come back in on that point.
>> Uh just a quick point on that. Given the
city in which we sit and given the
Oxford Movement's extraordinary outreach
to working-class parishes in the East of
London and other places, I hope that
those of you who adhere to that part of
the Anglican Communion will
resurrect the spirit of Father Faber and
get out there and make sure that the CAF
is not merely a middle-class talking
shop.
Helen.
Is this all right?
Um
without wanting to sound too
controversial, um are we not being
terribly arrogant thinking that somehow
we rather than God can change the mood
in this country?
The one thing I haven't heard someone
say is all the movements of the spirits
have come from the edges. Wesleyan, you
know, when we famously had revival, it's
actually about listening to God and
asking him how we should move rather
than us having all these theories about
how what's going to happen next.
Um I don't know how that looks like in
the Anglican Communion, but I would
suggest that all of us in the Communion
of Saints
would be doing well to really listen to
God's call and actually if we did that
might happen again, that revival.
Okay.
Um Raymond.
>> [applause]
>> I sympathize very much with what you
say, but you know, I'm reminded of the
old adage, God helps those who help
themselves. And so on the one hand, it's
also very vague and it sounds pious and
it's very appealing and I'm not against
it, but it also that kind of thinking
can lead to a lot of social paralysis,
which I think has been going on actually
for quite many decades.
So I I think it's a symbiotic
relationship as it always is with God,
okay? You know, maybe you of course God
starts and initiates, but you have to
work with him. So I'm all for listening
to God, but I also don't think that
should not become a sort of uh
uh call to just being in inactive and
you know, paralyzed and just waiting for
God to take care of everything. In fact,
I think that's the idea that to a
certain degree has led us to where we
are.
Yeah, I'd I'd
Uh think it's an important note to
strike, Alan, that sense of um
divine sovereignty over something like
revival, if that's what we're beginning
to see. Uh just two examples of that, I
think. Um
Uh
when I do confirmations around the
this diocese and and others, I very
rarely do a confirmation these days
without meeting a small group of Iranian
Muslims who have come to faith
um through some way or another. Some of
them in Iran, some of them have have
been come here and exploring
Christianity, uh largely because they're
turned off by the form of Islam that
they've they've encountered in Iran and
they want to find something else and
they're attracted by the person of Jesus
Christ. Now, no one planned that.
No one sat down and think, "Let's design
a a a
a revival amongst Iranian Christians.
Let's pick this country for it to
happen." Um
and it's a it's a kind of reminder of us
there is a sense of of yep, divine
sovereignty. We we go where
God is working. Another example I think
might be, we're talking about flags on
lamp posts. Uh what would a working
class revival look like in the country?
Where would it begin? Maybe it might
begin with people feeling, "Well, I
don't like the drift of where the
country's going and therefore um I want
to put a flag on a lamp post." And
that you know, there's also sucking of
teeth and clutching of pearls at that
and so on you know, within the Church of
England, but maybe that's the beginning
of a genuine working class revival. If
that's where God is working, let's focus
on that. Let's follow the
the lead of the spirit in that kind of
way. So, um
you're right, it can lead to a kind of
paralysis, but at the same time there's
something quite wise about seeing where
is God at work in the society we're part
of and following those leads and seeing
where that takes us.
A final question, very appropriately, to
John.
First of all, the bishop has
sort of
nuclear exploded my question to him
with his last remarks, but that was
simply a kind of intellectual tick when
he was in a sense being critical of
middle-class attitudes in the church.
I'm reminded of
the man who wrote news from nowhere.
Those who disparage respectability as
the tepid imitation of virtue are
generally the same people who cannot
live up to its un unexacting commands.
And and I'm not this is not a personal
remark, obviously. It's a it's a
rhetorical criticism, but I think that a
lot of people do enter
faith by interesting side doors.
And one of them is they look at the
people in church and they they want to
they say to themselves, well, I like
those people. I want to be like them.
Well, I can't understand it, but and and
a very wonderful expression of that in a
way is church-going by Philip Larkin in
which he is impressed
in part by the fact that this is a
sacred place. Why? Because many people
have worshipped here.
And in response to that, any final
final final remarks? We'll sort of go in
order of speakers if you want to start,
Graham.
Yeah, I I think we are in a time of
extraordinary opportunity for the
church, I think.
I think in a way there are sort of three
options ahead of us. I mean, there are
there are there are kind of two
indigenous religions in in Europe, which
is paganism and Christianity.
And we are kind of tempted back to
paganism to a kind of plurality of gods
that we worship. There's no such thing
as neutrality.
We have Islam as a kind of presence and
a possibility for the future.
But I think the the two big ones are for
me are paganism and Christianity. Which
is going to
come out of this. And so therefore
there's a there's a real need for us to
be confident in our faith, to be
positive in our evangelism, both in
public and in kind of in private
conversations. And that's where I think
I would we need to focus our our time
having that confidence in our faith,
not watering it down to that kind of
sort of liberal Protestantism that
doesn't really convert anybody as you
were saying earlier on.
But a full orbed Christian faith that is
strong about the gospel, strong about
sacraments, strong about the Bible, and
confident in the metaphysical claims of
Christian faith and the mystery and the
weirdness of it all.
David? Well, yes. I I agree. The only
thing I'd add is if you're Catholic, go
to confession, take the sacraments, and
get to the altar rail because I'm
saddened by the number of
Catholics
who far predate my reception to the
church who don't seem to find that
terribly important, think it's all about
going to mass. It's not.
Final thoughts, Raymond?
Final thoughts, um I just I just always
because I like to see things from a long
historical perspective and it's ironic I
find that the Western civilization,
Western world is
super powerful today, let's say compared
to Islam, especially since that's the
main topic, you know, militarily,
economically, politically,
technologically. And at no time in
history is it being more terrorized than
by Islam than today.
Um you have to remember in the medieval
era, Islam was the behemoth and Europe
was the embattled tiny bastion of
Christendom. And they they managed to
prevail. They fought tooth and nail
often times and they articulated it
through Christian doctrine, through as I
mentioned, two swords theology and just
war theology. So really when you look
and think about it, it's a lot of this
and what you're seeing is completely
self-made, self-done. It's initiated
internally. It's not because of external
forces. Because how can how can a
society be at its pinnacle, again,
materially, militarily, economically,
and be so terrorized by by all intents
and purposes one of the weakest groups
of people. Islam is inherently weak
today compared to the West. They come as
migrants cap in hand and then next thing
you know the country's being taken over
and they have blasphemy laws and the
native people and the Christians feel
like they have to accommodate them. So
that's pretty perverse development and I
think again it's important to keep in
mind that it's 100% internal. These are
not external forces that have created
this and that is what we're talking
about of course the internal change that
has led to this I believe and I think
we're all to various degrees saying has
to do with the shrinkage or truncation
of Christendom.
Well, I think to to summarize a lot is
at stake. The truth is at stake.
Everything is at stake and we're not
going to succeed except by God's grace.
So thank you very much to our speakers
and thank you all for your
contributions.
Bring back
the fire.
the flame.
Bring back
the fire
and the righteousness.